hello everybody welcome to the come AI
hackathon will give a minute to get some
people in here so it's generated by our
internal segment that was trained on
comic colouring comic erecting
cityscapes cam vids mapillary vista the
same ones everyone else knows we just
felt like I
what we owe ya my name is George for
those that don't know youtubers so much
now on this hackathon food what we're
really here to do is induce as much
follow as possible so you'll tell all
your friends you know which I was at the
comic i hack Athan i think that's a good
plan
fine tune on our stop hello Fran China's
gross ma'am what happened to twitch
things it's a new year it's 2020
I am rehab check out the kiddie
leaderboard it's pretty good for that
and I think it is that in video paper
small flick somatic segmentation on the
videos result okay we got a bunch of
people here I'll show you guys the
secret TVs what's made available we're
not going to disturb them here are some
fun projects to work on here is some
random projects to work on
here are some open project pilot
projects to work on and here is our
Wi-Fi network
welcome to the common hackathon where we
have kickoff and dinner some challenges
will come live tomorrow you can see my
terrible handwriting dinner lunch
presentations and then say goodbye howís
flex are going oh yeah yes I'm some some
common employees decided they were to do
flex raise their hand home project
for all the haters who said you can't do
flex rate with a logic analyzer and an
FPGA oh yeah
this is leak content guys welcome to my
office you know my office can
transceivers and a logic analyzer and
then hopefully that will allow us to
intercept the messages there's an Audi
q8 in the garage there's more lidar in
the common office right now then there's
ever been in history there's actually
three lied arse in here because there's
two lidar is in the in the Audi q8 yeah
this is actually all wrong this is the
a4 1 this is gonna be hard is it hard
oh man - the keyway have good drivers
system yeah but I don't need right 45
because all the traffic but a dinner
mess up go OK and I couldn't ride a
traffic jam assist I don't know I didn't
or something goes too many but it didn't
mess up and you were on the highway yes
it was like an agar B 5 to 10 seconds
did you have to wheel to reset it or
could you oh you're the wheel aha yeah
all right I don't know what else to tell
you guys you know next year or next time
it won't even be next year make sure you
get invited to the cava AI hackathon and
you could be participating in all of
this fun yeah that's all we got
bye-bye